kemah is a beautiful seaside resort in
southwest Turkey normally a place to
relax and rejuvenate for one weekend a
year however that peace and calm is
disrupted when the world's best off-road
riders gather here for the sea to sky
event they start from sea level
literally by the sea before scaling
Mount Olympus at an altitude of two
thousand three hundred sixty-five meters
it's always a good atmosphere you know
the like the tourists come they've
probably never seen anything like this
so there's a few had to turn in looking
what we're doing so introducing people
to the sport as well and some it they've
never seen the writers start day one on
the beach but hardly is bums this
opening stage of the race is all about
speed thrills spills and spectacular
jumps
you
twenty-one-year-old johnnie walker
leaves his rivals in the dust during
qualifying grabbing pole position for
the next stage
I'm feeling good but it's like every
other race I've been to this year I've
been feeling good but like girls burger
drama baked in the first war poodle and
then romaniacs I run out of heels
hopefully nothing goes wrong this one
then the battle against the elements
commences from the beach they head for
the forest as the mountain begins to
loom larger the terrain only gets
tougher from here onwards and the riders
will have to use all their skills to
prevail smooth and Swift sections are
followed by tricky technical parts
pushing man and machine to their limits
it's the kind of conditions that
two-time winner Graham Jarvis revels in
and he makes up ground on fellow
Englishman Walker
so if we win this year it'd be free wins
on the trot so would be a nice I'm still
hungry as ever still really want that
win as the race progresses it becomes
increasingly a quest for climbers rather
than cruisers on this kind of terrain
experience and technical writing skills
are decisive not horsepower even the
best of them struggle to overcome
seemingly impassable obstacles wielding
those heavy 100 kilo bikes around corner
after corner is visibly taking its toll
that's an immense physical exertion and
not just because of the terrain
the hardest part of this race I think
it's the heat with 30 more than 30
degrees and yeah that's the hardest part
for me and also in the up at the
mountain I heard about at our canyon
where dark canyon is the final grueling
stage of the sea to sky only the creme
de la creme make it this far the
exhausted writers have to summon up
whatever strength they have left to
conquer the summit it's been a
neck-and-neck race between Walker and
Jarvis ad there's just a few meters
separating them as the finish line comes
into view
Walker wins ending his streak of bad
luck the 10-second winning margin was
one of the closest ever and extreme
enduro I think the hardest part for me
was probably coming up towards the end
when when I seen Jarvis was catching me
I news coming out all day so I just I
just had to push and then the last four
miles maybe we were both going backwards
and forwards in positions and eventually
got ten seconds on him at the top and
that's how this flows John is very very
well so big congratulations to him in
third no small achievement here is an
exhausted alfredo gomez from Spain
for dougie lampkin and seemed the
torment would never end basically I
could see they could see the red balázs
here and I thought I was getting close
but I knew the bike was just coming to a
stop and then it looked like it was on
fire there was blue smoke coming from
under the tank and unfortunately
somebody was throwing water on me just
on that corner and then the bag just
stopped then and I knew there was no
chance trying to restart it and he'll
that was the end and and one of the
photographers puts his cameras down and
said let's push it and I thought I'm
looking I got some more friends to come
down and give us a hand and Johnny came
down now you know after winning the race
came down and got me through to the end
extreme enduro is the ultimate in
off-road banking but there's also a lot
of camaraderie between competitors only
the three guys on the podium get
trophies but every writer who finishes
the race is surely a winner